now for people that you may not know who
barry silas if you want to put up the
movie american-made so they know what
movie
american-made played by uh
tom cruise did you see have you seen a
movie or not yes it's a great movie by
the way do you think so i thought it was
a good movie i mean obviously the story
of uh were you not a fan oh it was just
terrible
really oh yeah well of course you would
say that because because it's your life
meaning you lived it so you know more
details than the guys it was just stupid
like okay if you've got 30 million
dollars in the airplane you're gonna bet
10 he can't take off because the
runway's too short who could even think
of such a yeah he's gonna put guns to
his head and take his sunglasses that's
just pure crazy and then all these
planes running through the yeah i apr
pioneered that course through the run
through the oil wells and they're going
to talk to the dea how are you going to
know what channel they own just like
it's going to go differently you're
saying a lot of that movie was just kind
of far-fetched i believe somebody
somebody sit in a
a rocking chair and read something and
said how could it have been did you did
you look at tom and say he reminds me of
barry or not at all oh not at all really
nothing barry looked like
looked like a statesman barry looked
like um
somebody should have been a
governor or a senator yeah like a
clinton like a bill clinton type of guy
good looking yeah and really smart
well-spoken all beautiful smoking he's
just gentle and southern gentlemen nice
and mad as you would have a mate
yes really you unbelie so so you guys
you guys get hooked up at this point who
who has more power
and more money between the two of you or
is a different kind of power and money
very worked completely for me i paid him
a salary you so barry
worked for you you paid him a salary yes
and he's flying for you at this time
that's right okay we know that happened
but we got so many years we we've jumped
over there so between those years of
jumping over what happened there did you
have any kind of connection at this
point from mexico to now you're doing
stuff with ochoa or pablo has anything
happened yet or not yet
no nothing's happened to them until i
guess 1980. but i i did uh oh i got a
twin beach airplane a friend of mine
says okay
you got shot down and you're shut up let
me buy you a twin beach they bought me a
beautiful one from i met the the beach
boys and boat their airplane that thing
was lovely
and uh went to atlanta and picked my
wife up and the red carpet was rolled
out that thing was just absolutely it's
like that red one over on the right
but back then that was so nice
and i still like that best of all of the
airplanes i flew
and
yes and so then i could i could haul
about 2500 pounds and i just haul load
after load after load and they
started operation star trek and they put
these trucks on the little hills all
across the border from
galveston to
tijuana but then i i would go out in
middle of baja 400 miles south of san
diego and go out to a 300 miles and come
in behind the islands of santa barbara
and come up and go out in the desert
unload just never had any problem
whatsoever
so it looked like i had it's like i had
a lifestyle how many people were working
for you at that time nobody it's still a
one-man show just in one-man show so
this is what
so always was this is still a one-man
show so at this time
um are you having the big life do you
live in a big house do you have the nice
clothes are you partying with the right
people are you being invited to
celebrities stuff like that or no you're
living a very low-key nobody knows like
the it's like the
millionaire next door or instead it's a
trafficker next door nobody would know
who you are is that kind of how it was
or not i don't know kind of a mix we had
a nice home in santa barbara you know in
hope ranch it's really nice on what what
is what does that nice home mean to you
well it was 180 000 back then it's like
50 15 million dollars now okay so that's
a really nice really nice oh yeah 50
million dollar home okay and
uh on a
on a firefighter salary oh well listen i
i quit the fire department and we moved
up to santa barbara my wife found a
house and i said you know we can't find
175 dollars how are we going to hide a
house she said we hide airplanes and
ships you can certainly we can have a
house yeah so
by the way this whole time you've been
with your wife yes same wife same wife
in and out of jail everything you've
been together 60 years 60 years strong
but we were married 58 we were
sweethearts for a year and a half before
that yeah i know how it goes all right
and how much how much in that plane that
you mentioned how much money gets can
you you said 2500. 2500 tons pounds
pounds
2 500 pounds i apologize how what does
that equal in terms of what the weight
that you're moving marijuana i was
making from 60 to 100 000 i flew it on
halves i didn't like to buy it or sell
it or load it or nothing i would i would
land somebody would put it in i would
come up kick it out somebody pick it up
and take it to him he didn't touch
anything
i didn't i didn't use it touch it buy it
smell it smoke it so did you feel like
you were a criminal at this point or is
it like look i'm not even touching it
i'm just the uber driver of the
trafficking business listen i never felt
like i was a criminal i'm an outlaw but
we outlaws for many things when you
break the law now it's not even against
the law after i got out after all those
30-something years there was a big
billboard said relax we deliver your
marijuana to your house
i think adam's trying to get ideas
that's what adam's trying to get ideas
on how to make that my next five minutes
who wants to buy that 50 million dollar
house in santa barbara i did
so okay so at this time you're you're
like you're living large are you
partying are you pretty located no party
in italy you're not a part of an
automobile are you a guy that uses the
product smoke sweet snorts coke or no
don't touch it you don't touch it you've
never touched it it's not touch it i
tried it i mean i don't know
but it's not something you're like okay
since i can inhale
yeah okay
well biggie said never get high on your
own supplies that's right no i don't i'm
not a druggie i don't use it so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]
you